"I don't know. The world is a big place."
"It used to be a big place," said Phileas Fogg.
"It's a lot smaller now," the bank director agreed.
"It is smaller because now you can travel around it ten times more quickly than you could one hundred years ago."
"You can do it in eighty days."
"I read it in the newspaper," said one of the other players.
"But there could be bad weather, shipwrecks, and many other problems that delay the trip."
"It might be eighty days on the timetables...
...but I don't think it will work if you try it."
"I'm sure it will," replied Phileas Fogg.
"I'd like to see you prove it."
"I bet 4,000 pounds that you can't do it!"
Each of the five players said that they would bet the same amount.
"I'll do it," said Mr. Fogg calmly.
"I have 20,000 pounds with Baring Brothers."
"I am ready to risk it."
They could hardly believe him.
"You will lose all that money if there is an unexpected delay."
"I do not believe in the unexpected," replied Mr. Fogg.
"When will you go?"
"Now. The train to Dover leaves at 8:45."
"I will be on it."
"Tonight?"
"Yes, tonight."
"It is Wednesday, the second of October,...
...and I will be back in this room at 8:45 on Saturday, the 21st of December."
"If I am not here, you may cash this check for 20,000 pounds and share the money among yourselves."
The six men wrote it all down on a piece of paper and signed it.